[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
holy spirit activate holy spirit
activate activate activate
and with that we welcome you back to the
break room some of you all don't watch
celebrity family feud and it shows it's
joe i'm okay with that
um
yeah no if you've missed one none of it
will make sense uh this is the
breakthrough remark daily show that
keeps you updated on all the nerdy news
that you need to know and boys are
always lots of nerdy news especially
this week uh coming up on the show today
we're going to talk about the she-hulk
release date you might not think that's
exciting but it's exciting uh warner
brothers is being wild
real wild we got rick and morty news and
news about the high evolutionary but
before we get up to all that let's get
to our guests today on the panel over
across the table we've got koi jondro
back in the studio so excited to be back
post comic con with you lovelies yeah
the king of comic con dude first comic
host on hall each i'm so honored
a lot of koi chatter in the chat already
guys a lot of koi boys and girls out
there a lot of koi boys out there uh
next of course we got jessica clements
hello jessica i made a face because
someone said hi from my shower
go off respect don't let you ever do a
shower beer yeah a shower beer but a
shower electronic doesn't sound like
you're on the side needles in one bag do
not electrocute yourselves this this
breaker this breaker is a millionaire
they got one of those big showers where
you can walk away from the water
shower
waterfall uh faucet thing oh yeah a man
who loves a waterfall faucet thing tommy
bechto yes shout out to niagara falls
both american and canadian side
horseshoe and the one that you die if
you go over
uh and i also wanted to give a special
gucci to mochi to uh our friend joe uh
who super chatted us three times
yesterday i think we did not uh we did
not acknowledge a super chat
i'm gonna give this to you one time
go browns and it pains me to say it but
the city of cleveland has suffered i'll
give you dog pound go browns not in
favor of your quarterback
and i'm brandon hello uh yes this is the
break room we're live in our very own
break room here at new rockstars hq uh
hey if you're still there go ahead and
hit that like button you did it i
and we've got a redemption today in our
chat for every 100 bucks we raise in the
chat through those super chats like our
good friend joe sent in yesterday uh
we've each written a little love letter
very private very personal uh but we'll
read them out for you uh you'll get to
well every time we cross a hundred
dollars we'll throw a pull up in the
chat and you'll get to see our super
secret love
letters maybe it's you and maybe you'll
find out today on the break group look
at us we're well on our way with
graveyard 3503 giving a a super chat and
saying i need more jessica talking
horror especially as the mcu horror gone
because the chat moved too fast
yeah more horror in the mcu jessica
loves horror bodies bodies i'm staying
at this bird
well they keep saying it's a thriller or
a bullet train i saw it last night it's
not a [ __ ] but it is gory they call it
a heart
it said on wrong tomatoes it's a
thriller hormone they don't know what
they're talking about okay okay riding
tomatoes get out of here
it's weird it's just an action movie
with a lot of gore and samurai swords
which i love it was fun
yeah the only thing rotten about rotten
tomatoes is the staff yeah
i like that i like that
but just stay on it
stay on that stay on that one uh and the
break room is also on tic-tac yeah if
you're a gen z and you love the tiki tax
uh i don't know what it is uh but follow
us at the underscore break room uh tommy
promised to do some dances on the tech
talk
don't worry there's going to be we're
filming two right after the show oh boy
to be released immediately yeah and
that's a threat not a promise yeah
that's something i say to get people to
throw their phones into the river mm-hmm
a river of phones
have a river of phones it's time for
headlines
hey
she will push the release date to
thursdays the new premiere date is
august 18th one day later than we
thought it was going to be yeah so it
was supposed to go it was wednesdays and
now that's what it takes to move into
thursday is it just uh not overlapping
with andorra i have no idea why they're
doing this if you remember uh disney
plus loved friday
yeah really says we were waking up we
were staying up late on thursday night
doing very early shows on fridays on
stereo for all you old new rock stars
fans out there
uh we were live on stereo early on
friday mornings that was one division
that was one difficult and then during
loki they switched it to wednesdays yeah
they switched it to wednesdays much
better for our schedules but now they're
taking a thursday route i don't know
maybe it is to get ahead of the android
thing
is this going to share two weeks with
andor because they moved indoor to
september they moved it back yeah yeah
so i assume they're just like
preeminently yeah and i also think it's
a better idea to have one flavor of
disney plus on one day yeah and then
another so
going forward maybe star wars wednesdays
marvel thursdays movies come out on
fridays we don't want anything yeah
unless you're online
yeah i think it's a movie thing i think
they learned from marvel miss marvel and
uh kenobi it was like it was too much i
have to watch one yeah
i think so much of the marketing comes
from like tick tock and on a day of talk
yeah you need to have that moment to
share that excitement and i think that's
separate but they've got all these
animated stuff coming too and it's all
so much content on disney playlists
really quick john they said that they
could hear a slack ping
pong
the opposite of the break room just by
its nature oh my god
we're supposed to be on break everyone
sent your slacks to not receiving
messages right now yeah and set your
headlines to our next one yes wb
discovery released a statement on the
scrapping of batgirl batgirl interrupted
as i like to call it yes uh
this was the quote from wb discovery
they said the decision to not release
batgirl reflects our leadership
strategic shift as it relates to the dc
universe and hbo max
that's what a spokesperson said in a
statement they also said leslie grace is
an incredibly talented actor and this
decision is not a reflection of her
performance we are incredibly grateful
to the filmmakers of batgirl and scoob
holiday haunt and their respective cats
we hope to collaborate collaborate with
everyone again in the near
future everyone's dictated but not red
no that's not the actor's fault everyone
knows it's not the actors
like what a baby maybe release two
separate statements they literally throw
it they're like we are also they're like
they're basically like reporting it like
the way you report like like your your
condolences for a death and they're like
we also want to just really quick say
sorry to the families of scoob haunted
holiday it's got an exclamation point of
the title so it looks like the worst
like memorial ever like go go
[Music]
also if you really do like that actress
make a like talk about it yeah talk
about it every instagram post she has
right now are people being like you're
not bad girl your show got canceled
yes they did the same thing no offense
star wars fans are the same thing to
christina ariel and i'm like you guys
speak up for your people when star wars
spoke up for her was like they were like
toned down yeah and they're not speaking
up for her they're just like i don't
know anything
yeah it's new leader you know
it's a crazy situation and i think the
more they keep it away from me the more
i want to see it yeah yeah you know what
it's working
i also have a little conspiracy theory
in my mind
uh discovery is trying to pull a little
disney here and what they're really
doing is they're waiting to release a
warner brothers movies
streaming service but they know if they
take all the dc content that has
succeeded or been released off people
will riot but the way they're
mysteriously pulling things off that our
warner brothers produced movies i think
you're going to end up with an hbo
streamer a warner brothers streamer and
a discovery streamer and guess what
they'll all be conveniently bundled for
one low price that you will have to pay
that is slightly more than uh you're
paying right now
look follow the money people they want
us to always follow the money it goes so
much deeper than this they want us to
watch their documentary so bad that's
right and look here i'm still not going
to watch it even when even when they
merge and everything's on there i'm not
going to watch it i'm going to be out of
out of respect for that girl i'm going
to be like nope not until you release it
okay uh in other wb news james gunn uh
reassured us that peacemaker season two
is safe amid all the cuts so that's one
what if he cannot see it again i think
this is a pretty good idea i don't know
as as producer john said i bet you that
the directors of batgirl were probably
pretty confident in their movie before
they were told it was cancelled well you
tell john cena that there's not gonna be
a peacemaker season two yeah you get a
little attitude adjustment
so you can't see them
uh
uh also at wb news we got some rick and
morty updates they released some of the
season six titles uh they have some
great you know if you if you're a rick
and morty head you know they're like a
little pun with their their titles i
won't share all of them but there's some
great ones like uh rictional mort poons
hmm
i don't get that one no there's two on
this list that aren't like rick jones
i'm sorry
analyze this which is
[Laughter]
which i hope is a sequel
to the anatomy part that they already
did
because the ending of that episode was
like we're making a better part right
we're making a better part well and then
the giant uh
dead hobo was in space right around
space and then did it crash did they
explode
next headline oh yeah john boyega
addresses mcu casting rumors your boy
john boyega is he going to be in the mcu
well he told men's health that a marvel
role is quote not in the vision for him
now
he went on to say that he wants to do
nuanced things that offer fresh ideas
hey
star wars fans thanks a lot i i shaped
the moon knight experience where i like
he didn't have to sign on for eight
years he did the six episodes i think
that might be the way to eventually get
john boyega back and i think like you
should kind of woo him because that
dude's incredible and i would be upset
too
that's the difference between john
boyega and oscar isaac because john
ballega has done a lot of big roles
don't get me wrong but i think oscar
isaac has just done a little bit more
especially with like ex machina and a
bunch of other things so it's just like
he feels like he can be like yeah i'm
just gonna dance i'm gonna dance but
john boyega it's like his dance can
leave him on like a really slippery
slope i think remember during like black
lives matter where he was protesting
yeah and people were like afraid to put
him in things and jordan had to
outwardly be like you always have a home
with me like he has a little bit of a
thinner line
he's a very honest man and i i respect
that and yeah you know i think he did it
seems like he had a rough experience
during the whole star wars yeah
he said as much too and then publicly
had a rough experience after because
like i understand him people are saying
our stream may have crashed
okay
well
here
me
if you can hear us or not we'll just
keep going
okay
all right well we'll never talk about
what we just talked about
again that was my darkest secret yeah i
think i think we might be close to
warner brothers studios and they could
be sending they were like they're
sending out a signal trying to jam
oh god i'm sorry warner brothers i was
just joking i take it back i take it
back oh my god
oh god i'm sorry warner brothers i was
just joking i take it back i take it
back oh my god i'll watch all your
streams all of them i love that
in our next headline star wars uh next
show is going to mirror us politics a
little bit in an interview with fiona's
uh in an interview fiona shaw said that
she quote or sorry uh it's fiona shaw
did an interview recently where she was
talking about andor the next star wars
series that we love to talk about here
on the show as you said quote tony has
written a great scurrilous story on the
trumpian world our world is exploding in
different places right now people's
rights are disappearing and andor
reflects that the empire is taking over
and it feels like the same thing is
happening in reality too
and petunia so a little bit of uh uh art
imitating life i think there's one thing
i know about star wars fans is they
handle news like this well yeah yeah i'm
sure this will go over very nicely yeah
yes yes i mean i'm super stoked for
andorra i i think this is an interesting
story to tell i hope they really get
into that new trailer like i've been
wanting more war in my star war
bring on the war and the espionage get
out of the sky we cut a guy in half
during kenobi we could do better so much
more put them halfway this way
imagine peeled apart oh yeah nice peel
of parts give him several cuts yeah he
stands there for a second and then they
all start sliding in different
directions that's the stuff we want to
see
next headline
she-hulk director says daredevil's
arrival will be a crowd favorite uh cat
choreo director of she-hulk said they
match each other's wits is what i can
say ah the entire time i kept thinking
that they were gonna battle it out in
court and i was like no they're gonna go
to each other for advice and be friends
i think they're gonna do it i think okay
i didn't say what it is okay i think
she-hulk and daredevil will initially
battle it out and then matt murdock and
jennifer walters will be friends
oh no yeah i think we're gonna find a
member and realize who they are
and i also think that this being comic
canon with her breaking the fourth wall
might be an interesting way to have like
the wittiness of charlie cox and then
her like reference us about him being
there like there might be some fun play
with that fourth quarter is there a
thing is there a thing uh we're like
it's the hulk and or she-hulk is like
superman where no one realizes
if you see the hulk are you like is that
bruce banner so she's publicly the first
superhero right she's putting her name
out yeah she's very known as jennifer
walter she-hulk but like she wouldn't
she wouldn't know that daredevil is
memorial murdoch unless i fear she can
smell it i i think she's going to be the
first one that easily is just like
you're matt murdock
i know i know that voice i know who you
are i know your boy you walk the same
way
okay i like that yeah i'm stoked to see
daredevil uh and she hulk um come to
blows and come to objections yeah i hope
they're on opposite sides like
i think we're gonna see like a bunch we
talked about the cameos and how often
they're throwing in cameos in the show i
think they're gonna have a bunch of like
c and b list characters and they might
be representing each side of them i
think it'd be fun to have like a
superhero court case where you got both
heroes at once
i can't wait for this they're going to
battle it out i'm excited to see them
better
i think it's going to play out like this
matt murdock brings over a nice chablis
to jennifer's house and then goes
uh permission to treat the co-counsel as
hostile and then she says
sustained
and then the cork just flies off like a
zucker brother's movement yeah it's like
like a naked gun thing and then cut to
the next morning and they go whoa so
that happened
then she says you are the man without
fears
actor mentions t'challa and chadwick's
major impact on neymar and himself uh
tanakh huerta had said quote well my
character and personally it is fun
because my character has a deep
admiration for black panther t'challa
but me as an actor and as a simple human
being what chadwick means it's so
powerful so deep it's extraordinary and
yeah it's a big inspiration uh end quote
so this is tonight's king that like he
himself really admires chadwick what
he's done with the characters his
character yeah he's also saying that his
character kind of admires t'challa and
black panther which is something that
i've been wondering is that you know
these trailers make it seem like they're
going to be at war
uh you know to loken or atlantis and uh
wakanda but i think that might be a
little
trickeroo by marvel and they might throw
a curveball at us and they're actually
kind of allies in a way i could see how
he would have respected the king that is
t'challa and maybe doesn't trust the new
king or the new queen depending on which
day they go and that might be a
that what we're seeing is like act one
and then they like superheroes do team
up like there might be a conflict and
it's like oh you are worthy of this
mantle yeah yeah because it being a a
mantle that's passed you've got to have
moments of conflict where like other
nations like doctor doom might not
believe in things that are happening so
i'd be interested to see if that leads
to our big bad being someone else yeah i
want the big like secret nation reveal
right this movie where it's like all
right all the secret nations now have to
show up come on just take away your did
you want that to happen yeah yeah i just
want like from nowhere feeling like 50
off and then in secret wars they all get
disbanded and then some brought back
together in different universes that's
when i emerged from my hill the chunky
boys come out oh the chunky boys we're
little tank boys we come out and go
that's our power by the way br stands
for boyce rule for everyone in the chat
wondering what br stands for oh okay
boys
yeah
it doesn't stand for it doesn't stand
for boys
yeah we ran a couple of polls in the
chat uh we asked what your favorite
season
season six episode title was you people
love analyzing
that because it's a route baby it's a
round for analyze piss uh we also asked
if thursdays are better for disney plus
releases
40 of you said no wednesdays are the
best
come on i liked fridays because i would
just stay up be really tired
all weekend immediately uh and then does
the recent android news excite you for
the series uh 44 said more excited 40
same 14 less excited uh if you're not
hyper and or what's wrong
come on get hyped for it yeah
don't forget to send in those super
chats uh we do have some secret love
letters oh my god some spicy we crossed
that hundred dollars uh the
mj2997 sent in a super chat saying my
secret crush was jess but then you
mentioned endor and now i'm conflicted
maybe you know what i can't he likes
cassian you can love all things equally
no
not in my life you got to love me or
nothing oh
jessica comes first always thank you
um okay so now it's on to our biggest
discussion where you guys probably
entered through the thumbnail the high
evolutionary is connected to more than
just it whoa
yes yes okay so we knew this if you read
the comics they're clearly attached to
they're clearly attached to everything
it's flirting with the camera
with the comments oh no there's only one
person i can play with the camera
jennifer walters of this room oh my god
i don't want to be matt murdock i'll be
titania so um that's how you say it
that's how i say it i've never said it
out loud yet
i thought it was kitty anna oh it's
obviously titty anna i've been saying
that raggedy andy's sister i don't talk
about apologies to
everybody that i've referred to as kitty
anna for the last i've been saying
titanium yeah i've been saying titanium
okay that's uh but i also to be fair
when i read comics i've been pronouncing
it my own way my entire life like
crimson bands of cinderella i'm like how
do you say that it's words that are made
up you're like i don't know we'll talk
about this because game of thrones
really built
so the high evolutionary is connected to
more than just rocket and in the comics
we know this he touches literally
everything but in an interview with
green rant uh chuck wuji says we're on
first name basis uh he's connected to a
lot of people and the effects uh and
affects a lot of people's lives in a not
so nice way which immediately was like
oh perfect adam warlock isn't really
going to be the villain did we think
adam warlock was going to be like no the
villain villain no he's like too
fresh to be the brother right he's a
baby yeah we don't know him yeah yeah so
then we have so the high evolutionary
and feel free to chime in because i i
haven't read about him since
ages ago but the high evolutionary
basically his entire deal is just like
seeing things and making it better in
his eyes uh the the cow that he made
into like a living sentient well cows
are sentient but like making an actual
walking nursery made like cow he just
takes what is there and tries to make it
better in his eyes and so in guardians
of the galaxy what better way than to
see adam warlock and be like how much
higher can i make this movie right
do am i the only one that's getting that
vibe of this could be another one of his
experiments i feel like the sovereign
are i feel like the song
i think he made the sovereign and that's
his like most great success to date and
rocket was like an early onset
experiment that didn't go well and then
he wants further success that warlock i
think the sovereign he's responsible for
the entire i think he made the sovereign
and once he walked away and he's like
that's my success and now he wants to
make adam more like even greater well do
you think okay so his uh has there been
a comics are you guys on this i'm like
has there been a comic where um
the high evolutionary created something
that created something else there
there's some like weird 70s continuity
where it was implied that he was
responsible for like a chain of events
so i'm not sure if it's linear like that
you know what i mean and they did tear
apart so in the early early days i guess
the high revolutionary to me when i was
reading didn't seem as bad he was just
in wonder gore just like i can create
things uh that's where um scarlet witch
uh magneto and his wife
gave birth in that place in front of the
high evolutionary and in front of the
cow but then later on it kind of got
retconned and he was like experimenting
on children in wondergore so he became a
monster uh around 2005. so
but if you look at the original like
cosmic stuff it always felt big like it
always felt like he was responsible for
like entire areas of like change in in
like over time so i feel like we're
gonna get more of that since it's james
gunn he likes to go back and like shape
so i feel like he's gonna be responsible
for maybe even some of our guardians i
mean i think rockets assumed but what if
he yeah what if he was involved in like
ego
like what if he was involved in like the
formation of a lot of these guardians
and then it's revenge for rocket revenge
for their story and they've got adam
warlock like on their side that makes a
lot of sense because i feel like james
gunn's
kind of stories for both volume one and
volume two they deal with like family
they deal with history how you come
together yeah the family you have that
you're given and the family that you
choose and like yeah your lineage
where you come from and what that turns
you into and he's been talking about
rocket a lot and he's been saying that
he's the saddest creature in the
universe and i think that the team is
going to team up to get revenge for
rocket i'm afraid rocket bites it very
early uh and i really think we're going
to lose a lot of guardians and i think
we're going to find out things about
them as they're getting oh no i think
it's going to be a dark dark time it
just seems uh and this is maybe this is
just me it seems so big to put the high
evolutionary and adam warlock in the
same movie that is less than three hours
long i'm assuming it's gonna be less
than three hours but like it's that's
such a big character those are both two
big characters and so i'm i'm just i
guess it's like
he has to be connected to the guardians
the high evolutionary right yes and
that's why you have time to because
think about how much more will be
invested in him if we find out he'd
messed up our boys so much and our girls
like if he's like yo i did this then you
skipped 20 minutes of screen time you're
like i hate this guy scroll down really
quick because this also goes with what
you said in an interview with collider
he went on to say that uh shady doesn't
touch it he is narcissistic sociopathic
but very charming i couldn't have
thought of a better character that uses
skill set better to join the mcu with
because there's something very
shakespearean about him there's
something very emotionally dark about
him and he's a lot of fun to top all of
that i am so he is literally going to be
like why are you mad at me i created you
yeah i made you a life you're having fun
i can make you better i can make you a
better rat raccoon thing you can think
about rocket the whole time he's like he
doesn't identify with being a raccoon so
from the beginning he doesn't feel like
he doesn't even know what a raccoon he
exactly so he's like i'm not that thing
and he's always like very like you know
like arms distance keep away from me
i've had this whole thing so now that he
has a family we're going to feel way
more from getting ripped out of it and
we're going to feel more when he does
it's and it's implied that rocket
escaped from because that's his thing
right he can get out he's very smart
he's tactical because i was wondering if
like the high evolutionary if in this
story you know you say like he creates a
sovereign if he like he likes to create
things and then like walk away maybe
that's your mic uh you know like he he
builds
societies or he builds people he
engineers them he's like i'm bored i
want to like go to school i want to make
something bigger i want to make
something better it's it's so
interesting because i like maybe it's
because i really like villains that i
was completely like
i love the high evolutionary i recognize
i recognize being like i could push this
towards its potential like i can make
this bigger and better him and thanos
are basically the same deal yeah like
it's
except for i don't know well thanos
wanted to get rid of yeah
i i always like the the villains that
like they make so huge in scope that
they treat the characters the human
character or at least the humanoid
characters like their game pieces like
they're like oh i made you or i created
you i set you up where i wanted and it's
my you know i can wipe you off the board
as as easily as i want and that's how he
was treating us in the room and whole
age the actor came out and was like you
things in this room you remind me why i
create yeah like it was very much that
tone that was great in a room graveyard
3503 said something that i mentioned
before where the high evolutionary
creates mutants in space leads to mojo
world mojo
everybody wants them but i i agree
mainly with the first part which is like
but is that too big for james not too
big for james gunn that maybe that's not
the right phrasing but like for him like
maybe he did create a mutant yeah like
the high evolutionary could absolutely
have created a mutant like one of them
could not one of them maybe on the
guardians actually it's possible could
be a mutant and he created it he not
created the gene completely yes but
that'd be a lot to tell you i i am
curious how they eventually you know go
further than spoiler alert for sure that
ended ms marvel but i do feel like we're
going to start to see more and more
mention as we lead up to because we're i
mean d23 is what seven weeks away or
something like that we're gonna have i
assume some major announcements so it'll
be interesting to see what they tell us
before things like guardians 3 because i
do think it's it's almost inevitable we
get an expert announcement at d23
they said they're going to fill in a lot
of phase six so i think there's got to
be something in there at d23 23 the
break room working hard to get there
guys yeah if you want us make sure you
let them know you want the break room
yeah you're if you're sally chey pick
tell your dad that's right
i'll tell you that lying down on the
chat says is the high evolutionary
gigantic in the movie though i don't
think he's going to be yeah i don't know
but he didn't he beat up galat no did he
beat up galactus
i think he did didn't he i remember that
he beat up someone
to show that he was strong it was one of
those power struggles
i need to go back and read it they're
gonna put him in space right but he
won't be earthbound right it won't be on
wondercore mountain or anything like
that yeah i think it's gonna stay out
the sound space i'm wondering if there
would be any connection between him and
like nebula because we haven't
learned much about nebula's past and
she's clearly a foundation
because the trailer that was that great
moment of like that that awkward
reconnecting and she's completely
unaware of who he is do you think that
uh thanos could have been looking at him
as like inspiration and like just worked
on his daughter like getting parts from
him or something like a new arm he was
like i could make a better thing and
then his daughter's like i hate you
because you keep tearing out my limbs
they were part of a similar facebook
group yeah yeah it was like they're
watching each other youtube modifying
like people mods yeah yeah yeah they
went to the same poker night and
everyone loved their revolutionary
they're like oh yeah
i'm going to take out hacking
i could know the daughter just let me
get these stones you can see what i'll
do we touched on it uh briefly this will
be my last question because we need to
go quick uh some people are gonna die
people are gonna die but specifically in
guardians of the galaxy three so do you
think adam warlock will be the one that
dies or because do you think he's too
important to the franchise more
important than the high evolutionary i
think will poulter is
going is so beloved already he's going
to be another thing yeah i think he'll
put on those muscles for one minute
still looking great at comic con
no that's sticking around
revolutionaries
i think they can both survive that's
what i think but i'm also like where are
you gonna put them in phase five the
high evolution i think you save it i i
think they're a long game i don't think
they come back to the secret world
nasty you have a guardian's film end
with the bad guy
not yeah if anyone's going to do it as
james got not being put away if anyone's
going to do the bad guys win and maybe
maybe the guardian sacrificed themselves
to to subdue stop him like but he
doesn't get eliminated
look at tragic stuff which is a good
symmetry to the uh to the first movie
where they all thought they were going
to die to kill yeah and they were
willing to go together yeah this is like
toy story three yeah except it's going
to end with the incinerator
oh they all actually and then they'll
make a fourth one that there's
unnecessary yeah
let us know in the chat make that call
if your luck's gonna die or if you think
the high evolutionaries listen to me
listen to me listen to me last night
i i had a tough time sleeping and this
morning i woke up in a cold sweat i know
i couldn't shake the feeling i was being
watched there was a strange feeling on
my sheets and the unmistakable scent of
crop preserver on my skin
and that's when i knew
i had sleep manscaped again
what a way to wake up oh my god shorten
like a sheep oh no we want to thank
manscape for sponsoring the break room
this week the grooming package i highly
recommend is the
performance package 4.0
this electric trimmer is bush's worst
nightmare okay the trimmer is designed
to reduce grooming accidents and shave
hair on loose skin thanks to the ceramic
blade and advanced skin safe technology
no need for night vision goggles
although i think it's fun to turn the
lights out and just go to town on
yourself this trimmer has an led light
to allow you to mow the lawn in the dark
just like my uncle did before we lost
him forever
with a performance bait he used to mow
the lawn in the dark and then he just
went into the woods one day okay lawn
mower yeah all the way you could have
just followed the trail to the
uh you'd think it was that easy
ah with the performance package you've
got two free gifts coming your way the
shed travel bag and the patented high
performance reduce chafing manscape
boxers baby free underwear in this
economy they have a bunch of other
products on their website to help you
maximize your confidence and your
grooming game trust me
keep it tight down there keep it light
up here that's what i say get 20 off
plus free shipping with our code break
room at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
here's the important part use our code
break room okay
let them know we sent you when you're
shaving those things all right keep your
lawn clean and pristine with the
ultimate bushwhacking tools from
manscaped
yes thank you manscape yeah you want to
have a little fun in the sun make sure
you're manscaped wait what you want to
have a little mandatory fun that starts
right now
that's right the segment that has swept
the nation every day i gather my three
very best friends and i force them to
have a little non-optional fun with me
in a segment we call
mandatory fun
i didn't even ask him to play it again
he knew
uh the segment's so nice we're going to
play the clip of neymar talking that we
didn't play earlier hit that clip click
forget it
it is fun because my character has a
deep admiration
for black panther
sorry i forgot to tee up the clip
apparently but tommy didn't be pretty
yeah
and he didn't even correct your ad i
didn't know
i liked you i liked your performance of
it dummy and i'm gonna wait i like your
performance of it okay i'm allowed to be
a fan okay
the segment this is the segment so
exciting that we're going to play the
other clip we promised the higher
evolutionary who's been around for eons
is actually he's connected to a hell of
a lot of the characters in this movie
i don't want to interrupt anything but i
we see your chats about moon night
season two and we will get to it at the
end yeah we're not talking about
moonlight season two and scoop them out
they're going crazy in the chat board
someone said eternals too got confirmed
as well marvel's just like we're gonna
really stick it to dc today
yeah d23 soon guys hey you know what
maybe d23 is a little packed and those
just slipped over the old soup they got
seven seasons of bad match to talk about
at d23 guys
well
the future of dc eu is certainly in flux
with the cancellation of batgirl as well
as several other warner brothers
projects
man i miss the camera every time as soon
as i go over there it goes back over
there so we have decided
we have decided to forecast
some of the dc projects john is
switching the future of them all we have
three categories we have safe
we have danger zone and we have
eliminated
all right so bring out my board
i'm sorry you're okay you get mad at me
for not helping and then when i do help
you i'm sorry i didn't do it on purpose
we've got the big board here better wear
closed-toed shoes at work that's right
everyone should be wearing non-slip
shoes restaurant style yes chef
the chef herd chef perfect
all right behind corners cousin 86 half
the movies all right cousin what's 86
yeah 86 halfway we're gonna i'm gonna go
with some stuff i'm gonna go first oh
okay this is why i think it's safe
aquaman let me tell you why mamoa's out
there pushing water on airplanes i saw
the picture today he's got a new water
brand he's pretending to be a flight
attendant
oh he's i thought yeah
i think they're working it out
it's not okay with me
not okay with me you make a vow you
honor it
right jason if you're on the chat let us
know hopefully jason let me know who you
are it's like i'm completely happy and
okay all right anyway uh we can all take
turns here okay you want to go next you
go for it i know you got i know you got
one in your heart um i don't have one in
my heart okay i thought that that was
one specific no there was i i told you
guys not to talk about it oh okay
are you easy
it's got a release date now yeah october
4th october 4th yeah at 25. yes i'll be
62. okay i'm gonna make it's it's
slightly more it's going to be oh
okay i'm excited
anticipated right there incredibly bold
predictions
that's that's safe you did great safe
all right
doctor wiping his brow thank god that
one's absolutely i'm gonna go
uh i'm gonna take another risk okay
something i think
probably should happen
oh well well take it off the board take
it off take it off the board you know
what i might just be called the flash
yeah
whoa whoa
actually no you know what i'll do i'll
do it right here
how are you going for it i'll say i mean
batman 2 is safe yeah batman too is
something not batman this is not a
reason no batman robert patton said the
batman more nirvana you're going to love
it yeah i love nirvana washington go
ahead i mean
come on i guess that's gotta be yeah
that's that's
pretty good about it i'm gonna put
another tweener
i think the amanda waller series is
leaning danger zone just because i feel
like all creative parties involved might
just be a little sick of this [ __ ]
okay it's a lot of the old like guard of
that yeah yeah supergirl's done it's
done right it's already cooked oh
yeah at the last at the last uh
convention they did when they did the
entire panel they were like we're sad to
see each other go oh oh
i thought i thought we were talking
about the movie
that's been done
okay this one feels pretty obvious i
don't even want the easy one okay all
right wonder woman three okay are you
going with it gal gadot patty jenkins
hanging out in london yeah claim they're
making a movie yeah we have no idea
i think they might cut it wow
i agree with you this would mean
dc eu restart after
because i think you can do
this and
this yeah and build a new corner of the
airport which was the whole dc panel we
just had
and then this becomes the gods and then
the hierarchy of the dc universe is
changed yes i think they will json i
think they'll keep gal gadot as wonder
woman yeah i'll put her in stuff but not
i'm so understanding this won't be this
won't be because of gal gadot or
patty jenkins no this is all because of
the water brothers it's the money i'm
gonna do something right now okay all
right it's called sleuthing because
there's another world's greatest
detective
i think colin farrell's thirsty thespian
moment yesterday is because he knows
something he knows his tv work
ain't happening and he wants back in the
movies
gotham penguin show you think it's
eliminated
you think it's the limit
what what did he say yesterday he said
he'd love to be the penguin again he
said he's done a lot of acting that one
was a cakewalk mate he'd be happy to
return to the role
yeah so matt reeves there was an
announcement that he's no longer
directing the show
so that does this is scary this is scary
sorry i scared y'all i guess i'm just
willing to if matt reeves isn't doing
this i don't want to watch it and it's
because he did so well and i want this
whole universe
and that's the thing people are always
like they forget the director's direct
actors right and i think matt reeves did
really well directly
i think colin farrell is one of the
better actors we have working that
doesn't get to do things like that often
so i think he's pushing for it like your
quote but i also think that i wanted the
matt reeves batman universe like as a
total 100 percent well we've got it safe
we've got the batman i want i want this
to be like the mcu sure like i want to
live in it i understand but for now
i can't confirm it i'm only putting this
in the danger zone because warner
brothers made it very warner bros
discovery made it very like
abhorrent that they're like we didn't
even want this one as our batman and we
want to go in a different direction
so it but
i did see the reshoot photos where he is
in aquaman too right but
warner bros discoveries doing such crazy
stuff right now that watch them just
take i think this is these two together
put these two together oh it's like a
little batman in a wonder woman movie
because i was thinking that this might
like this being bye-bye might be why
he's in aquaman
he wanted to say by the character stuff
okay because if this is gone i think he
wanted to get his last bat flight back
yeah because
that's some good detective work now
we've got three left i mean we know this
is safe that's right yeah i think that's
safe
please put
put black canary just for my own soul
and safe okay what are they announcing
we're doing this for jessica jessica
jessica turn away that we know about
blizzard turn around jessica look at
that beautiful look at the yeah that's
awesome
i'm not saying anything anyone doesn't
know it's safely
dead now this one's interesting because
this did very very well for what they
wanted it to be but it came out at a
weird time like the box office wasn't
what it was yet but people loved it and
then i think this helped it i'm gonna go
just because of the shakeups yeah i just
feel like we don't know this and this
feels similar yeah yeah i was like
amanda waller and that are going to be
there james gunn truly is done with
marvel and he's done telling stories
over there and he still wants to do
superhero stuff like this is yeah they
would probably give them a lot i feel
like this and this would be the great
way to go and have like james gunn and
matt reeves kind of spearheading like
double fighting you want james gonna do
am i the batman you're not saying like
sharing the universe
oh james
i gotta be honest we're being way too
merciful because i have a feeling a lot
of these are gonna be eliminated in this
danger that's what the danger zone is
yeah you're right you're right it's a
dangerous you're right but i'm just
saying
i mean i wanted this elimination
yeah i will put the henry cavill i think
you're right i don't think i think he
has no interest i hope black canary goes
but it's just like i mean if they're not
doing batgirl i would hope that maybe
during black history month they're like
oh we should actually do black and white
well yeah
obviously optics aren't a huge
connection
this is for me because i want it plastic
man i just this is for me i don't know
you guys aren't going to erase his or
put it over here i'm just going to go
ahead and turn around yep on this side
is it safely dead it did safely dead
and you know what he's just over here
i'm putting this here
the rocks just like outside all right
that was mandatory fun we'll find us
everybody take a seat
now we are over a hundred dollars and we
owe it to our fans to let jessica read
her letter and then be so moved that
they give generously so we can read our
letters i worked really hard on mine
mine's really personal who do you want
me to read my letter to read it to the
camera but who is it about it's your
love letter
i don't know you're supposed to pick
this is my love letter to
john
john this is you
oh i did but you're my neighbor you sit
right across from me okay
all right
are you guys ready i'm ready
dear john
the book
dear john
uh i would never have the courage to say
this so i'm reading it aloud in front of
our peers oh my god when you smile my
heart skips a beat when you wake at me i
melt oh i wish i could be more than your
neighbor we're already so close take a
knock on my door baby oh if you give me
at least 20 minutes i could show you how
great we could be together
i realize out loud that this sounds kind
of bad
i i i don't want to even say the rest
i can juggle and i can do the splits i'm
pretty funny and i can make you laugh on
occasion i love to cook and i'm a great
reciprocator my gift to
him to receive ratios three to one whoa
truly i hope this just made you jump
rather than uncomfortable i'm bad at
pitching myself but i do adore you and
even a life next door as your friend and
neighbor is a life worth living and a
life well live three to one three to one
give me those odds i'm just oh my god
here we
us up are we belong
yes
this thing i first bonded as friends
when she would come over to my house and
sit on my front lawn for like three
hours and i was like i have to go
editing and i was like i need to keep
venting
oscar isaac and muhammad daib who was
one of the directors from moon knight
were spotted in cairo
and then
when asked by a fan if we were going to
get a season two diabetes had a season
two of midnight and then oscar isaac
said why else would we be in cairo
marie posted it on his twitter and said
moon night season 2 question mark
chrissy
christie
i also wanted to share eternals too uh
patton oswald was on like the today show
or something don't have facts uh don't
fact-check me but he was on a talk show
and was just like casually was like yeah
eternals two's in development closed
are these just thirsty thespians like
calling that's what i think he's saying
it's gonna it's gonna come out
ignore them i don't know what's
happening here's your microphone i can
move
back i'm so
i'm so excited for moon night season two
i'm gonna wall out if we can't worry
chrissy christie was awake guys she sent
in a super chat yes uh saying moon night
season two i am vibrating with you yeah
i'll be available on standby for all
your egyptology nerd knowledge i will
say mr
jtw
which means i love you all i also like
that crazy said i'm so awake right now i
could kill a building
yes now i mean i
see people saying they want me to read
my love letter now i will if we get to
150 we're at 115 now 35 more bucks guys
you got five to maybe seven minutes to
do it yes thank you for all those stupid
things thank you for giving me uh film
juice every time i think about the dc eu
i got a nosebleed feel that uh jenny
davis sending a super chat yes moon
night season two
uh are you guys gonna talk about the
video that the moon knight produces put
out with aaron
we just didn't
that was from ishan miraja i mean guys
we were doing a show we can't always
just be looking at our phones just
reading twitter
i asked if i could constantly be online
during the show and i was told not a
good idea it was not a good thing they
laughed in tommy's face that wasn't a
funny thing but then we just keep
hearing the pornhub theme right yeah
everyone knows it
kaden thomas sent in a super chat saying
did you all see the shaya coulee from
rudra yes yes we did it we talked about
it tommy told me i broke through
baby let's go
you better work honey
you can stay our winner our normal
winner our everyday winner of our hearts
it's giving ironheart yes jay brad in
the ghetto center the super chat saying
this is phase wong well rob will wong
play in wakanda forever aka wong konda
forever oh he's
i do want that cameo i'd be okay with
the camera that's just like nah i think
wong is uh like our nick fury of this
space yeah i think like he's gathering
the young avengers and he's putting
people in the right places together he's
not going away any time soon but if nick
fury did go please just make it wrong
just make sure it seems our wong and the
uh everybody that's all the
sorcerers or as john said
is wong a scrawl
i'd be so heartbroken that would be
earlier it'd be a great it'd be a great
twist
he's like trying to manipulate the
avengers by like leaving them
any scroll any scroll that has been
embedded in the mcu for a while and
doing so much good they're fine by me
yeah
they're good guys so far the scrolls
we've met are good yeah yeah we've met
so far scrolls good awesome oh my god
we're 15 away i can't i can't do it i
said i would said 150 i can't
give up my principles again
yes
three to one i'm stuck on that i'll be
here
it is in the prompter and we try to get
to it every day
we're like
waiting we got break we got breaking
news we got aching news all right
tommy's gonna read his love letter throw
a like on the video if you haven't
already please and tommy share your love
is my with the breakers my dearest
our love is of the forbidden variety
but it runs as deep
as the deepest ocean
i think fondly of our time in hawaii
as we spent the days diving amongst the
waves collecting shells and raising hell
in the end
it could never work between us
your home is the ocean
and my home is the combination taco bell
kfc on la brea in washington
i'll never forget the time you ate a
manhole just to defend my honor or the
time you ripped a guy in half
well that made my heart whole again
i love you king shark
and i always like
finn
oh
[Applause]
shark genitalia or human genitalia well
i don't want to speak out of school but
let's just say a little bit of column a
a little bit of column
i know that in the harlequin series
you're supposed to make love to someone
but they never do ron shout out to ron
funches who kills that folks you don't
need human genitalia to make love i mean
no 100 that comes from the heart yeah
that comes from the heart sure
guys we're still doing our clip of the
week here at the break room so if you're
on our discord thank you so much if
you're not on our discord what are you
doing or maybe you're under 18. you have
to be 18 to be on the discord but submit
your favorite clip from any episode
during the week and we will reveal our
favorite submitted clip at the end of
the week so make sure you do that we
also got a voicemail on our discord
sending some voicemail questions some of
you have already i know we haven't
really done it yet on the show but we're
working on the technology we got to get
the voicemail sent in i just got a
theory oh okay in this moment uh
eternals two high evolutionary connected
whoa
well there was one poll that i wanted to
talk about real fast uh we asked the cha
other than rocket who do you think the
high evolutionary will be the most
connected to and 45 said mantis we
didn't mention mantis well because if
you think they could get to like the
celestial madonna and all that stuff
with mantis via the high evolutionary i
think we could in like in a piece i
think the seed could be planted here and
i think the reason we might have
eternals too is we find out how things
went from how humans got evolved on the
planet maybe he's responsible for us
maybe there's more things through the
celestials because the celestials made
the eternals and the eternals identify
with humanity maybe there's something
connecting all that that we find out
more of because we still haven't had
people talking about the things sticking
out of the planet like there's still
like a lot of things
by the way someone mentioned that
so many movies and tv shows mentioned
tmz
is real people as a lover of eternals
this is my this is a big moment like
this happening
moonlight's a huge deal for me i'm going
off i'm gonna be weird this is my top 12
mcu film maybe top ten the turtle is a
big deal this is this is
exciting i'm so glad you could be on the
breaker online john could maybe tell you
about it he knew a little bit thank you
john for coming in with all information
and thank you for watching the break
room today we love you breakers roomies
and all your trash bags out there uh i
hope you have a great rest of your
wednesday be sure to tune in tomorrow
and on friday we're here every weekday
on the break room live from our very own
break room here at new rockstars
headquarters uh throw a like on the
video have a great rest of your day
latest gators we'll see you in season
two baby
[Applause]